it's the first of august 2022 so it's
time for another monthly update video in
which i'll tell you about what went on
in july that you might have missed and
want to get in on
and we'll also talk about all the cool
stuff coming up in
this long month of august i always begin
by highlighting three big things so big
thing number one
august is my birthday month i will be
having an online birthday bash that
everybody is invited to doing some live
streaming on youtube just to hang out a
bit with people that you know like the
videos or podcasts and stuff like that
and want to
celebrate and chat so that'll be coming
up on the 18th
coming up also this big thing number two
a little bit earlier in the month i will
be in person for another
philosophers in the midst of history
talk this time focusing
on
hegel and we'll be talking about his
place in history how he was formed his
ideas on history that we'll be at the
frank weinberg library i'll talk more
about that coming up
and then finally big thing number three
i've started making use of this feature
in youtube to add
fundraisers that you can contribute to
on some of my videos and you know i'm
finding good fundraisers to go along
with it so
you know for my cat videos i've got
things that have to do with the urban
cat coalition and for other videos other
things and you'll be seeing a lot more
of those rolling out and youtube
collects the money for the various
charities and i think it's a really
great thing so that's the
big scoop on those three big things now
let's talk about july
we did quite a few things in the month
of july scott truly and i got together
for another classic metal class in which
we talked about
rebellion as a theme in metal we had
some great guests who contributed to the
discussion as well
and
you can check out the video for that
link to below we also had worlds of
speculative fiction going back to an
author who used to be when i was uh
younger my favorite author roger zelazny
looking at the second part of the
chronicle of amber series we did an ama
as usual every month a lot of great
questions um half hour hegel sessions uh
and i've also been teaching two classes
online one of which just finished up
this weekend and that is with milwaukee
institute of art and design that's an
academic intro to philosophy class for
my students there but i've been doing a
light hall class on
aristotle and the moral virtues that has
been
really a lot of fun and some great
engagement and questions with that i'll
probably be re-running that class
sometime
in the winter or the coming year
wisdom for life
we were able to have a couple recording
sessions and that that's good
um lots of meetings with clients for
philosophical counseling and tutorials
and uh even a few other
connected things as well um my my wife
andy and i have been to a number of
concerts and you know you know some of
which were going to summerfest here in
milwaukee the world's largest music
festival but some other things
as well and i'll mention another cool
thing that we did we we drove up to
green bay to see a soccer game that more
or less got rained out at lambeau field
but while we were there in green bay
maybe some of you have seen me put stuff
about this in social media
we visited a cat sanctuary
which serves um you know cats who've
been injured or cats who are near their
end of life kind of hospice stuff and
i think many of you know how attached i
was to sassy
among other cats and um you know she's
been gone about three months now
so
you know sitting there holding a a cat
who's slowly succumbing to cancer
in my lap and just hanging out was kind
of a nice thing to do and i'll probably
do more of those things in the future
um video work put out a lot of videos
this month uh one of which is following
up on that series of fake quotes right
we did plato we did aristotle i asked
people who they wanted next and they
said marcus aurelius so i did one of a
bunch of fake marcus aurelius quotes as
it turns out there's a lot of them
floating around out there
i also did a couple um
videos in a series that i hadn't touched
for a while answers to common questions
about stoicism
which may be helpful for people we did a
really cool thing as well
in worlds of speculative fiction not
only did we have our regular monthly
thing on roger zelazny but i also got to
interview
uh james kennedy a recent author of a
really great speculative fiction work
called dare to know
and
that was a you know really fun
conversation because he's he's great at
the back and forth repartee and we got
to go really deep into the metaphysics
and even some of the back history of his
his uh recent novel which you should
check out
um i did a lot of things on speculative
fiction this month actually i
did a whole series on do androids dream
of electric sheep the famous you know
philip k dick work that eventually was
adapted into the blade runner and then i
decided to do another set of speculative
fiction studies videos on
an address that dick gave
the android and the human
i got one book review done on donald
robertson's
verisimos a graphic novel about marcus
aurelius and we did a caption contest
video which was a lot of fun
as well
i also
sampled some of the video recordings
from my aristotle on the moral virtues
light hall class that actually people
really liked that quite a bit so i'll
probably do some more of those
in the future giving you a little taste
of what the class
was about and the kind of topics that
we're going into and then of course i
did a couple half hour hegel videos
one of which has been released one of
which is not
for uh you know the project
um released to patreon supporters that
is both of them have been released to
the supporters of the project one has
been released publicly and so that's
that's it for videos i was pretty busy
with podcast work on the sadler's
lectures and
um
did you know we wrapped up the series on
augustine's confessions it turned out i
had a lot of episodes on that and then
we went into anselm's on truth
and we just finished up plato's fedo
and
so you know it was it was a pretty good
month as far as podcast stuff goes so
that's that's july
let's talk about what we've got coming
up in august now all the dates are the
same as you know what i'm saying but you
got to be careful about the time because
for every online event i'm giving it to
you in central time which means that you
need to check out what time zone you're
in if you want to participate every once
in a while i have somebody who comes in
at the end and says oh i got the time
zone wrong so
on the sixth that's coming up this
saturday i have my ama that's ask me
anything session you can jump in and ask
me questions they can be about
philosophy they can be about other
things people ask me questions about
heavy metal my back history all those
sorts of things so you're welcome to
join me for that and then a little bit
later on the sixth for my patreon
supporters at 2pm i will be having my
philosophy chat session which is a
little bit more intimate and we go into
a bit more depth and detail
on the 10th if you're here in the
milwaukee area
at 6 00 p.m at the frank weinberg
library that's in mequon so you know on
the north side
we will be having the aforementioned
philosophers in the midst of history
session devoted to
hegel and i will be going deep into his
own you know biography and and you know
his place in history how he was shaped
by history how he shaped history himself
some of his key ideas because he is a
philosopher of history we'll be going
into
all of that and you know we usually have
a pretty good audience asking questions
so that should be a lot of fun if you're
here in the area you definitely want to
come out for that
on the 13th at 12 p.m and then at 1 30
p.m we're gonna have the two different
parts of the worlds of speculative
fiction series we begin with a video
premiere in which i talk about the
author and the books and you know what's
going on in them philosophical themes
world building we do live chat while the
video is running and then we have a zoom
session where we continue the
conversation for those who
want to uh jump in
there and um who are we doing this month
jg ballard we are looking at his
novels of modern dystopia so high-rise
is one of those and
concrete island and
crash so that'll be a lot of fun
on the 17th at 5 00 p.m we have our
public hegel q a and discussion session
you don't have to be a member of the
half hour hegel project for that
as a matter of fact half our hegel is
underwriting that so if you'd like to
join in
on that i'm happy to chat with you about
hegel german idealism whatever it is
that you want to on the 18th it'll be my
birthday so at 1pm i am going to have an
online birthday bash it's going to be
kind of unprogrammed i'll just be
chatting with people and i'm sure
there'll be a lot of people wishing me a
happy birthday and i'll be saying thanks
and you know we'll talk about whatever
people want to talk about i'll probably
have some some reflections to start us
off about aging and you know philosophy
but you know
we'll see where it goes right
uh on the 20th at 12 uh that's that's
noon central time we have our classic
metal class me and scott tarrouli
will be
discussing a topic as yet to be
determined he and i have got to get
together on that and then on the 25th at
6 pm we have our online milwaukee stoic
fellowship
where we're often joined by people from
outside of milwaukee you don't have to
be in the greater milwaukee area to
participate in that and we will be
discussing diogenes laertes's summary of
stoic doctrine in book seven the life of
zeno looking specifically at matters and
ethics and then finally on the 27th at
noon
political theory and practice discussion
i've been putting it off
quite a bit as you know scheduling
didn't work out for previous months but
i think we'll we'll probably hold it
this month so
those are the events
obviously i have classes starting for
milwaukee institute of art and design i
may have some other academic classes in
the area starting up i just got
contacted over the weekend by a local
university that wants to bring me in to
teach
so we'll see if that happens i'm also
going to be having light hall classes
that are well i'm finishing up the
aristotle one and then i'm getting ready
for a
plato one that will begin
in early september so you know stay
tuned for that if you're interested in
those sorts of matters as far as video
production goes
i'm going to be doing some core concept
videos and at the very least i'll be
doing some
on somebody that people have been asking
me about for a long time arthur
schopenhauer
and i'm going to be doing some
a sequence uh that's coming from the mid
part to the end
of his uh on the basis of morality that
i i need for some of my ethics classes
the ethics of sympathy and you know his
discussions of that sort of thing
i'm going to try to make my half our
hegel quota for the month we're we're
you know
deep in the religion section getting
close to the end of the work which is
kind of cool
book reviews i got a lot of book reviews
i got to do and i i gotta get those
turned out because the books keep piling
up so i gotta work on some of those
there'll be videos of course of the
various events i'd like to get started
with doing interviews again in the ideas
that matter
sequence so that would be kind of nice
if i get the chance i might do another
like special worlds of speculative
fiction interview as well
and i'll probably do some personal
videos you know i always get a little
bit reflective around the birthday time
so you know there's some stuff i could
probably do as well as sadler stories
videos
and
um
you know i'm going to do at least one
more fake quotes video calling out these
fake quotes that people keep circulating
around
who it's gonna be on i haven't decided
it might be seneca it might be cicero it
might be epictetus i gotta kind of put
my feelers out there about who it should
be
and as far as uh podcasts work i've i've
got some podcast episodes on alcoin uh
his great treaties on virtues and vices
that we're gonna put out and then i
think i'll probably do another
you know poll and see who people would
like next i got plenty of material
on
aristotle and on epictetus and on some
other people that probably you know
could be uh
good to put out there but i'll run a
poll and you'll see it in my social
media so you can participate in that
and that is pretty much everything
that's going on here
um obviously i'm still getting to the
gym if you if you see my social media i
talk about that quite a bit still taking
walks in the beautiful milwaukee area
and uh looking forward to my oldest
daughter coming up here back to
university of wisconsin-milwaukee to
resume her studies and we'll get
together and have some some fun time as
well so that is what's coming up i hope
i see you
in some of these online events and maybe
some of you all you know if you're at
the face-to-face event
at the uh frank weinberg library come up
and introduce yourself to me and and
i'll be happy to chat with you after we
uh before or after we we do the session
so that's it i hope all of you have a
great month and i'll see you
somewhere in the internet ether
you